[Musik]
hände weg von meinem Haus das sagen
heute diese Häusle Besitzer bei Bild und
noch viele viele mehr die uns genau das
in den vergangenen Tagen und Wochen
geschrieben haben die Angst vor dem was
da kommen soll sanierungszwang das
Verbot von Öl und Gasheizung diese Angst
ist groß unter Deutschlands
häuslebesitzern Ministerpräsident
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Markus Söder
jetzt bei Bildgröße Sie herzlich Herr
Söder können Sie den deutschen
häuslebesitzern ein Stück weit diese
Angst nehmen
nein das kann man leider nicht in die
Pläne von Habicht sind tatsächlich voll
gegen jeden gerichtet der ein Eigentum
hat und sie sind eine extreme Belastung
für viele Menschen die kein großes
Einkommen haben ich verstehe auch nicht
warum Robert habe genau das zu mir
jetzigen Zeitpunkt macht die gesamten
Hilfsmaßnahmen sind noch gar nicht
abgewickelt zum Teil funktionieren sie
auch nicht komme nicht beim Burger an
für Öl und Pellets Heizungen
beispielsweise gibt es immer noch kein
abschließendes Verfahren durch den Bund
genau in einer solchen Situation kommt
der nächste Hammer nämlich zu sagen wir
verbieten Öl und Gasheizungen selbst das
Handwerk ist eigentlich den größten
Vorteil damit haben könnte er sagt wir
haben weder die Wärmepumpen noch die
Möglichkeiten einen solchen Umbau
vorzunehmen es gibt übrigens auch gar
nicht genügend Strom dafür um diese
Umstellung zu machen und die Kosten sind
so hoch dass es für viele Menschen
tatsächlich ein Abstieg also sozialen
Abstieg bedeuten könnte deswegen kann
ich nur sagen ein völlig abgehobener
Plan der darf auf keinen Fall Realität
werden
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Markus Söder
hat Kraft und ist auch Wort gewaltig
können sie nicht sagen ich stoppe das
ja wir suchen Partner dafür wir haben
letzte Woche schon auf der Länderebene
diskutiert die erste Auswirkung war ja
dass der niedersächsische Kollege die
gleichen Bedenken äußert wie wir was in
der Punkt wichtig ist weil er in einer
Koalitionspartei der Ampel ist das muss
natürlich innerhalb der Ampel gestoppt
werden wobei man ehrlicherweise sagen
muss man fragt sie überhaupt auf was
sich diese Ampel überhaupt einen kann
außer auch Verbote für irgendwas
passiert ja relativ wenig ist ein reiner
Streit Club geworden und an der Stelle
wäre arbeitsstreit notwendig um das zu
verhindern man darf ja nicht vergessen
verschiedene Pläne die zusammen gehen
der gleichzeitige Plan der Europäischen
Union diese Energieeffizienz bis Ende
des Jahrzehnt maximal zu tunen geht er
genau in dieselbe Richtung die Pläne
beispielsweise der Bundes Wohnungsbau
Ministerin beim Wohnungsbau des Eigentum
nicht mehr zu fördern sondern nur noch
den Mietwohnungsbau zu unterstützen geht
in die gleiche Richtung im Grunde
genommen sollte der Traum vom Eigenheim
der soll in Deutschland dauerhaft
zerstört werden weil man eine andere
uniformierte wohn Frau denke hat
deswegen glaube ich braucht es da mein
grundlegendes Umdenken vielleicht eine
Zeitenwende für bezahlbares Eigentum und
gegen super Belastungen und bei den
Grünen fällt mir nur eins sein immer das
Lied von Major Tom völlig losgelöst von
der Erde so wirkt diese ganze Politik
sie haben gerade schon ja ein Bündnis
sozusagen mit Niedersachsens
Ministerpräsident angesprochen was tun
sie alles denn um diesen Plan diese
Vorhaben diese Gesetzesvorhaben zu
stoppen
ja im Grunde genommen wir werden auf
jeden Fall ein Bundesrat tätig werden
sollte das tatsächlich Realität werden
diese Pläne sind tatsächlich eine eine
echte Attacke auf all diejenigen die in
der sozialen Mitte sind man spürt ja
auch richtig aber weil sie das in
Deutschland eine neue grüne soziale
Frage entsteht die Grünen sind auf dem
Weg zu einer reinen luxuspartei zu
werden die Mitte der Bevölkerung die
sozial schwächerin scheinen sie nicht zu
interessieren denn genau all diejenigen
werden durch diese Situation besonders
belastet übrigens schlagen sich diese
Dinge dann ja umgekehrt auch wieder auf
Mieter durch wenn man so ein Zwang
machen würde gegenüber Vermietern das
heißt es ist auch nicht nur gegenüber
den Eigentümern den Häuslebauer den
Häusler besitzerland Angriff es ist doch
generell eine Schwächung des gesamten
Wohnungsmarktes auch der Mieter werden
am Ende belangt und deswegen brauchst du
einen breites Bündnis dagegen er breit
ist Bündnis gegen diese abgehobenen
Pläne und natürlich muss auch die Ampel
selber Stellung beziehen und das ein
Bundeskanzler von der SPD das am Ende
unterstützen würde das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen das wäre falsch
deswegen muss auch Olaf Scholz das
Stoppen also Argument dafür ist ja klar
wir müssen irgendwie die Klimaziele
erreichen das sagt die Ampel das sagt
vor allen Dingen der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister Robert habe geht den
Klimaziele erreichen ohne solche Verbote
ohne Verbot von Öl und gasheizung
wir schauen Sie wir könnten noch was
anderes machen lassen wir die Kerne
Mecki laufen gibt ja viele Forderungen
dazu gestern hat die
Bundesumweltminister noch mal
ideologisch hart gesagt auf gar keinen
Fall wenn man allein wenn man allein die
keiner möchte laufen lassen würde sogar
noch etwas ausbaut wenn man stattdessen
Kohle einstellt dann würde es am Ende
dazu führen dass wir ungefähr den CO2
CO2 Ausstoß von fast einen Drittel des
gesamten Pkw-Verkehrs in Deutschland
sparen würden das ist doch das Problem
wir sind ideologisch auf einem falschen
Weg übrigens ist es auch falsch Gas aus
den USA allein zu beziehen und nicht in
Deutschland im Norden Deutschlands nach
Gas zu suchen und es zu erforschen auch
das ist ein riesen co2-verlust den man
hat indem man Gas in den USA umwandelt
in Flüssigkeit das über den Atlantik
schippert bei uns wieder umwandelt in
gas also die Klima Bilanz dieser
Regierung der Ampel und auch der Grünen
stimmt von vorne bis hinten nicht und
dass die Grünen lieber auf Kohle statt
auf
zeigt eigentlich dass es ihn nicht um
CO2-Reduktion geht sondern um reine alte
entschuldigung wenn ich das sage linke
Ideologie und das führt halt dann
schlicht auch dazu dass man nicht neuen
Verfahren offen gegenübersteht und
versucht dann an anderer Stelle das
wieder einzusparen auch wieder zu Lasten
ideologisch gesehen das Eigentums und
derer die ein kleines Häuschen haben und
sich das echt nicht leisten können eine
Häuschen zu haben das bedeutet
eigentlich Wohlstand vor allen Dingen
dann fürs Alter Ruhe zu haben sich keine
Sorgen machen zu müssen wird das immer
mehr von einem wohlstandssymbol zu einer
Last so ein Häuschen
ja wir gehen in Deutschland insgesamt
ein Weg eines wohlstandsrisikos wenn wir
anschauen wie teuer die Energiepreise
sind und bleiben werden und die
Energiekonzeption des Bundes wie gesagt
das kann eine geh auszusteigen selbst
Gast nicht zu explorieren nur darauf zu
setzen dass wir von anderswood viel
teurer Energie kaufen führt zu einer
schleichenden d-industrialisierung zu
einem dauerhaften Abbau von Wohlstand
und sind wir ehrlich es wurde ja
versprochen es gibt jeden Tag fünf neue
Windräder also mit den
genehmungsverfahren die sie auch jetzt
durch Berlin zwar erleichtert aber noch
nicht vollständig umgesetzt sind geht es
nicht das bedeutet ja dass in einer
Woche fünf Windräder mal 7 35 neue
Windräder auf den Weg gebracht wurden in
den letzten zwei drei Wochen ist es
nicht passiert und übrigens nicht wie
manche meinten in Bayern anderswo
genauso es fehlen übrigens auch die
gesamten Verteilungsnetze die da sind
und deswegen mache ich mir wirklich
Sorge wie das da weitergeht hinzu kommt
noch dass man in Deutschland nach
ungleich agiert ganz besonders das
Flugzeug benachteiligt werden wenn ich
beispielsweise an wasserstoffnetze denke
die sollen alle nur im Norden
stattfinden keins im Süden deswegen
werden wir jetzt auch im südnetz ist
zusammenschließen auch da Partner
Baden-Württemberg sogar Rheinland-Pfalz
und Saarland und über wasserstoffnetze
zu reden weil sonst alles zu teuer wird
wissen wir zu der Tatsache dass einige
aus der grünen Partei fordern wenn sie
mich zu kurz sagen lassen höhere
Strompreise zu zahlen höhere Strompreise
im Süden zu zahlen das alles führt nur
zur wohlstandsversivverschiebung und am
Ende dann zum Verlust von Wohlstand hast
du einmal beim Häuschen bleiben wenn sie
jetzt nicht bei uns Ministerpräsident
werden sondern der Markus aus Nürnberg
würden sie sich in diesen Zeiten 19
kaufen
es ist zumindest nicht schwere
Entscheidung wir bräuchten noch bessere
Förderinstrumente also die KfW sie
erinnern sich an das KfW-Programm das
von Robert habe gestoppt wurde zulassen
viele neue Wohnungen die gebaut worden
und hat man einen kleineres aufgelegt
was nicht ausreicht so dass viele
Wohnungen und Häuser nicht gebaut werden
wir bräuchten im Prinzip eine neue
Eigenheim zu Lage der Bund und ist eine
klare Forderung muss eine
Eigenheimzulage auflegen damit auch
wieder Eigentumshäuser gebaut werden
könne denn das ideologische Kampf gegen
das Eigenheim wie es insbesondere grünen
führen ist falsch und deswegen braucht
es in Deutschland eine neue
Eigenheimzulage und ein neues
Baukindergeld sind sie selbst eigentlich
betroffen von dem angekündigten Verbot
von Öl und gasheizung
wir schauen insgesamt in der Familie was
wir haben wir haben sehr viel umgestellt
in allen Bereichen und man wird sehen
was dann am Ende rauskommt generell ist
das Ziel alles erneuerbar zu machen ich
kann mir aber alles leisten mein Problem
ist nicht dass ich mir wirklich leisten
könnte oder alle Familien sich das nicht
leisten können die sagen wir heute
Politik machen die sind ja alle gut
bestellt aber es geht um viele Menschen
die sich das nicht leisten können die
heutige Ausgabe der Bild zeigte mir
viele betroffen sind und man darf auch
nicht vergessen wenn mal was vererbt
wird nicht jeder ist so reich bei der
Erhöhung der Erbschaftssteuer durch
Christian Lindner kam er eh schon eine
hohe Belastung für die Hauseigentümer zu
das heißt das wird belastet
Energieeffizienz Europäische Union Gas
und Ölheizungen werden verboten im
Grunde genommen hat man den Eindruck
dass dem einen anderen in der Ampel am
liebsten mehr wir würden alle wieder im
Platten baut wurden und jetzt kommt auch
noch die Grundsteuer mit dazu als
zusätzlicher riesen Aufreger für
Millionen Deutsche Häusle Besitzer die
Grundsteuer und die Sorge dass sich die
vervielfachte in den nächsten Jahren
so einen großen Aufstand gegen wie bei
der Grundsteuer haben wir in Deutschland
noch nie gegen gesteuert Millionen haben
da gar nicht mitgemacht erstmal haben
ihre Erklärung nicht abgegeben vor allem
weil man die nur digital machen konnte
und jetzt gibt's schon Millionen
Widersprüche mittlerweile eine Aufstand
wie wir Nieten
also wir in Bayern haben die Frist
deutlich verlängert weil es eben sehr
viele Menschen gibt die tatsächlich
damit Probleme haben es auszufüllen wir
versuchen auch Beratung zu machen Sie
ein bundeskonzept wie in Bayern übrigens
haben von der Möglichkeit Gebrauch
gemacht regional etwas andere Konzepte
zu machen um das abzumildern weil in
anderen Bundesländern wird es massives
massiv erhöht worden wir haben es
deutlich abgemildert diese dieser
Vorschlag weil wir nämlich auch finden
dass es zum Teil sehr unfair ist aber
das ist ein bundesvorschlag den
Kommission übrigens auch nach dem Urteil
des Verfassungsgericht passt aber wie
sie sagen zurecht genau in diese
Entwicklung hinein noch einmal wir
brauchen einen Pakt für Eigentum wir
brauchen Bekenntnis zum Eigenheim und
deswegen müssen an der Stelle noch mal
alles überprüft werden was geht es
braucht zinsverbilligte Darlehen für den
eigentumsbaus macht eine Eigenheimzulage
und ein Baukindergeld und keine extra
Steuererhöhungen deswegen klagen wir in
Bayern übrigens auch gegen diese
Erbschaftssteuerreform weil die
insbesondere den Gegenden in den hohe
Zuzug ist wie beispielsweise im Süden zu
hohe Grundstückspreis Preise gibt so
dass jemand der heute ein Häuschen habt
zum Beispiel in Oberbayern der kann das
gar nicht behalten der muss das quasi
verkaufen was dazu führt dass die Heimat
ausverkauft wird und andere abgegeben
wird und es kann nicht sein bei
niedrigen und mittleren Einkommen sagen
Experten immer so ist es eigentlich ganz
gut so maximal ein Drittel fürs Wohnen
auszugeben jetzt sind viele schon bei
50% oder sogar noch mehr was fürs Wohnen
und die ganzen Energiekosten dann noch
mal oben drauf drauf geht wo finden Sie
es für niedrige mit reinkommen so eine
Grenze die nicht überschritten werden
dürfte
ja das das kann man das kann man
unterschiedlich interpretieren jetzt im
Moment ist es einfach viel viel zu hoch
und es muss runter nochmal da entsteht
eine neue grüne soziale Armut die
Treiber dieser ganzen Entwicklung sind
ja die Grünen die anderen werden sich ja
nicht dagegen aber die Grünen sind der
armutstreiber in Deutschland
mittlerweile geworden ich will dir gar
nicht sagen dass das Motiv nicht gut
gemeint war aber die Umsetzung die
stattfindet und die Geschwindigkeit und
der Druck der ist ideologisch gepresst
und der geht zu Lasten vieler Menschen
die sich das einfach nicht mehr leisten
können und es führt natürlich zu
sozialen Spannungen Verwerfungen auf
Dauer und das dürfen wir auf Deutschland
auf keinen Fall akzeptieren am Ende
werden andere politische Kräfte davon
den Ertrag haben und deswegen braucht es
eine dringende Umkehr eine
Neuorientierung ein packt eben pro
Eigentum zum Schluss ganz kurz Herr
Ministerpräsident das Wackeln wieder
Banken plötzlich das kommt für all die
die das jetzt nicht jeden Tag beobachten
total überraschen und wir haben in der
letzten Banken und Finanzkrise erlebt
dass das eben auch für uns gefährlich
sein kann wenn irgendwo eine Bank
wackeln jetzt ist sogar relativ nah eine
große Bank in der Schweiz die ordentlich
gewackelt hat und jetzt übernommen wurde
ist das für uns auch gefährlich müssen
wir sorgen um unser Erspartes haben
jede Bank jede große Bank die
international tätig ist die wackelt ist
eine Herausforderung für das
Finanzsystem das ja genau der Grund
warum man anders als bei Lehman Brothers
bei der Silicon Valley Silicon Valley
Bank in USA massiv eingeschritten hat
und warum man das jetzt auch in der
Schweiz macht die Summe die man merkt
die zur Absicherung da sind zeigen
übrigens dass die Probleme der
jeweiligen Banken viel viel größer sind
ich hoffe sehr dass die gesamten
Wirkungsmechanismen die auf den Weg
gebracht worden sind helfen aber es ist
wie immer das gleiche in den
bankenmanagement Fehler passieren
plötzlich ist der Staat wieder sehr sehr
wichtig es zeigt ich würde das Thema
jedenfalls sehr sehr ernst nehmen und
der Bundesfinanzminister sollte sehr
bald einen Bericht darüber abgeben wie
die Finanzsituation der deutschen Banken
ist erst letztlich der Chef der BaFin
der Banken auf sich ja hoffen wenn sie
sagen hoffen macht mir das ehrlich
gesagt noch ein bisschen mehr Sorgen
ja ich kenne die Details in der gesamten
bankenbildung für Bayern zuständig nicht
für Deutschland und deswegen ist die
Übersicht da leichter bei dem
Fachgremium die Bankenaufsicht in
Deutschland sind eigentlich sehr streng
deswegen dürfte so etwas in Deutschland
nicht passieren muss man ausdrücklich
sagen es dürfte eigentlich nicht
passieren aber natürlich aufgrund der
internationalen Verpflichtungen wenn
eine Bank fällt dann ist es zumindest
kann es schockwirkungen haben und man
sieht es ja auch in den Kursen in den
Börsen die dann entsprechend reagieren
trotzdem durch die Rettung dieser Bank
und durch die Aufnahme der Bank durch
eine andere scheint die erste Gefahr
stabilisiert zu sein aber man muss
aufpassen im Ministerpräsident danke für
das Gespräch
wie immer gerne
[Musik]